- [Voiceover] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of
the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Professor Carol Greider
who is the Daniel Nathans
Professor and Director
of Molecular Biology and Genetics
at Johns Hopkins
University Medical School.
She won the 2009 Nobel Prize
for Physiology or Medicine
along with Elizabeth
Blackburn and Jack W. Szostak.
Professor Greider is the 2014
Hitchcock lecturer at Berkeley.
In 1885 the Hitchcock Endowment Fund
was established from a bequest
made by Dr. Charles M. Hitchcock
to institute a professorship
at the University of California
for free lectures upon scientific
and practical subjects.
Professor Greider,
welcome back to Berkeley.
- Thank you, it's nice to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in, actually,
San Diego, California,
but I was raised in Davis, California.
- Looking back, how do
you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Well my father was a
physicist at UC Davis
and he very much encouraged
me and my brother
to be able to follow what
we were interested in
and to try and keep all doors open
and very much encouraged us to be able to
explore things that interested us.
So I think that that really shaped
how I thought about a career.
- And your mother also
had a PhD from Berkeley.
Both your parents had PhDs from Berkeley.
- Both my parents had PhDs from Berkeley
although my mother died when I was young
and so it was my father that raised us.
So his influence on, sort of, where I went
is what I remember most.
- Was there a lot of
talk at the dinner table
about scientific matters?
- Sometimes, usually about physics,
which was a little bit above my head,
but, certainly, it was clear that
being able to pursue what you
were interested in was a goal.
- Because of your father's
role as a professor,
part of your early
years were spent abroad.
- Yes, he was on sabbatical
at the Max Planck Institute
in Heidelberg when I was 12.
So I went to Germany and was
put into the German Gymnasium
and, as a consequence,
learned to speak German
either the hard way or the easy way,
depending on how you think about it,
just being thrown in and immersed.
- In biographical material,
I've read about you,
you had an older brother and
your relationship with him
was very important and
both of you developed
a sense of autonomy and independence,
even by walking to school.
- Yeah, walking to school
when we were also in,
when we were young, but also in Germany
and being able to get around on our own
through the public transportation
when we were 12 and 13.
It was important.
- Were thinking skills, critical thinking,
just something you absorbed
with the atmosphere,
a physics professor
father studying abroad,
even as a young person?
- I never really thought
of it that way so much.
I didn't think of myself as somebody
that was particularly
good at critical thinking.
I was just trying to follow
things I was interested in.
- In your early years
you had dyslexia, right?
So you had to develop, drawn
this independence and autonomy
to figure out how to really cope
to make up for what you couldn't do
with things that you could do very well.
- Well it wasn't clear what
dyslexia was back then.
All I knew was that I had to be
taken out of my regular classroom
for this remedial spelling
and then I had a lot
of trouble in spelling
and, it wasn't really defined as dyslexia.
So it wasn't until I
was a little bit older
and looking back, that it was
clear that it was dyslexia.
So I think that's part of what contributed
to my feeling like,
maybe I wasn't as bright
as some of the other kids were,
but if I worked hard, I
could still do what I wanted.
So that was sort of the
image that I had of myself.
It was embarrassing to be
sitting in grade school
and have a special teacher come in
and take you out of the classroom
in front of all of the other kids.
- But you learned to compensate, really,
and develop coping strategies and skills.
- Later on, they ended
up being very useful.
I remember in my high school biology,
when we had a lot of
memorization with anatomy.
We were doing anatomy of the cat
and I found it very
easy to memorize things.
I realized, retrospectively, that that was
probably because, when I saw a word,
I couldn't sound out the
word and so, instead,
I would memorize it.
So that developed those memory skills
that ended up having
advantages in other settings.
- Did you have any teachers
before you went to college
that helped further what was
to become your interest in science?
- I was very interested
in biology in high school.
It wasn't necessarily
something that I said
I wanted to have a career in.
And I wasn't one of the
kids that did science fairs
or had a chemistry set.
But when I was a senior in high school,
I thought biology was interesting
and I was interested,
particularly, in marine biology,
which is what prompted me then
to choose UC Santa Barbara
as the place to go for
my undergraduate work.
- For you, Santa Barbara
was a special place
because of a special college
within Santa Barbara.
Talk a little about that because it seems
that you really developed
some important skills there.
- Yeah, so, in addition to applying
to the University of
California at Santa Barbara,
I also applied to the
College of Creative Studies.
And I knew about this because
there was professor there,
Bea Sweeney, who had been
a colleague of my mother's
and my father still kept
in contact with the family.
She was a professor of biology
within this integrated college.
So, literature, science, math,
arts within a small group.
That was particularly wonderful
because there was a lot
of individual attention.
Each student had an assigned advisor
and you could develop a
curriculum with that advisor
without necessarily having to
take certain blocks of classes
as the rest of the university did.
I found that very wonderful
'cause it allowed me to
be able to do experiments
in laboratories earlier
than I otherwise would.
- You really got into the science
and doing the experiments
across different areas.
Talk a little about that.
- Yeah, so, I remember when Bea
Sweeney, who was my advisor,
said to me as a freshman, she really felt
that I should be working in a laboratory.
I remember being thrown in as a freshman
and having all of these
college classes and, again,
thinking that I wasn't as smart
as all of my other colleagues.
And I thought, well that
would be overwhelming,
and she said, "I think you
should try it anyway." (laughs)
(Harry laughs)
And so I did and I started
off in a laboratory
doing some ecology, beach ecology.
I quickly learned that,
although I was interested in biology,
that area of biology didn't
really fit my way of thinking.
It was more statistics.
So then, through Bea Sweeney,
and interactions with her,
she was able to help me
get into several different
laboratories at Santa Barbara
and it was when I got into a laboratory
that was doing more biochemistry,
where one could really
look at what we now call,
sort of mechanistic interactions,
how you make a change in a system
and then you can see the
outcome of that change,
that that really fit my
intellectual way of thinking.
So that was really a wonderful opportunity
to test out different areas.
Because sometimes you can't know
what is most interesting to you
until you're actually in the environment.
- So it was a matter of self-discovery
what really worked for you
and, interestingly enough,
it sounded like you
wanted a physics dimension
to the biology you
- well certainly
a physical dimension, yes--
- a physical, yeah.
But that's what physicists do, right?
Yeah, so that's,
that's fascinating.
But the structure, the
curriculum structure,
and the mentoring, sort of helped you
find what it is you actually wanted to do.
That's rare, sometimes, in
undergraduate education.
- Yes, and it also helps because
I also took a year abroad.
Because I already spoke German,
I was able to take a year
abroad at Santa Barbara
and go and study in Göttingen.
So it was my second year abroad then
and it allowed me then
to take the courses there
and fit them into my academic program.
So, in taking a year abroad,
I still graduated in four years.
- It sounds like a lotta your experience
made you observant of people
and different kinds of people, in a way.
Is that fair?
I mean, to be immersed
in a foreign environment
at a young age and then doing it again,
it must have helped make
you an observant person
of the differences out there.
- Yes, I mean, I think that
that is certainly something
that I was always aware of is,
people and interactions with people.
So, I think that, because I
liked that, I liked going abroad
and the going abroad then helped me
learn to do that as well.
- Now, then, after getting your BA,
you came to Berkeley
as a graduate student.
Talk about choosing Berkeley
and why you wanted to be here.
- Well, when I was applying
to various graduate schools,
again, one has to take standardized tests
and, because of my dyslexia,
first for the GREs,
sorry, for the SATs and also for the GREs,
I didn't do so well on those.
So, of the 13 places that I applied to,
only two considered me
for the graduate program
and one was Cal Tech and
the other was UC Berkeley.
My advisor, Bea Sweeney, at the time,
she said, "Oh, you just
wanna go to Berkeley
"because that's where your mother went."
And she advised me,
instead, to go to Cal Tech
to do something different.
(both laugh)
But when I came to interview,
I was very captivated by the
program and, specifically,
my interactions with Elizabeth Blackburn
during my interview here, and
that's what really swayed me
to come here rather than Cal Tech.
- What were the years
that you were at Berkeley
and what was Berkeley like then,
just atmospherically, in general?
- I was here from '83 to '88.
It was a wonderful, open
intellectual environment
and I very much liked the interactions
with my classmates in the
molecular biology department.
People really were interested
in what other people were working on.
Friends would talk, not just about
what was going on socially,
but, mostly, it was about experiments.
There was a lot of
support amongst the group.
So, today, many of my best
friends are still the students
that I was here with at
Berkeley during my PhD.
- I like to ask my guests what they see as
both the skill set and the temperament
that are important for
the kind of work you do.
- What they would see or what--
- What you, looking
back at your own career,
and doing the work that you do,
what is the skill set involved?
- Being able to be able
to have the freedom
to do something that one's interested in
without, necessarily,
worrying about obstacles.
I think that that's something that
is different today than it used to be.
People are a little bit more
worried these days about,
what are they gonna do for their career
or what might get in the way.
But, I certainly felt,
as a graduate student,
that I just wanted to
do what was interesting
and I didn't really see
that there were limitations or obstacles.
Now that may be unique to me
because I learned early on,
perhaps through the dyslexia,
to just put blinders on,
and when I saw something I couldn't do,
just to ignore the fact
that I couldn't do it.
So it's not clear to me if I
was unique in that setting.
But, certainly, I felt that
I was extremely encouraged
to follow what was interesting
and not worry about any consequences.
- You had some choices once you were here
in terms of what you would specialize in.
What was your thought processes like?
Had your experience at
Santa Barbara sort of
pointed the way, so to speak,
in the choices you made there?
- I knew from Santa Barbara that
I liked this sort of
mechanistic way of thinking.
That was in both biochemistry
as well as in molecular biology.
But conversations with some of
my mentors at Santa Barbara,
Kevin Sullivan and David
Asai, were really saying,
DNA is the way of the
future in terms of where
these kinds of interesting
questions are going to lead.
So that, then, prompted me to apply
for the department of molecular biology
rather than to the
department of biochemistry
because, naively, I thought
that there was more of
that in molecular biology.
It turns out that it was
going on in both departments
but that's what I was sort of looking for,
was something where one could study things
in a very mechanistic way
and understand the DNA.
- So you decided to work
under Professor Blackburn
and you became interested in her work
and extending her work in telomeres.
So help us understand what a telomere is,
yes.
- Yean, so it's the very
end of the chromosome
and Liz had been working on
this for a number of years
and it was something that I hadn't
really heard very much about.
So I was particularly interested in it
because it was a little
bit out of the main stream.
But they are the ends of chromosomes,
the functional unit at
the ends of chromosomes
which are essential for
protecting the chromosome ends.
- So it's like a little cap.
- A little cap that
protects the chromosome end.
But it turns out that, in addition
to protecting the chromosome end,
it's important for maintaining
the length of the chromosome.
That was something that, at the time,
Liz and others were recently
aware of, that the way that,
When you copy a whole
chromosome, it turns out
that the way you copy a chromosome,
the very end of that
chromosome, the telomere,
can't be completely copied to the end.
So there was this mystery about how it is
that the end of the
chromosome can be maintained.
Why isn't it just that
the telomeres get shorter
and shorter and shorter
every time a cell divides?
That was certainly the prediction.
So, we were interested in
how that problem is overcome.
- As you begin this work and
really extend it over time,
you're, and I've learned
this in interviewing
the scientists who've come aboard,
you're actually on the back
of people who have preceded
you and made discoveries.
So let's just talk a
little about that so, in,
let me see if I have this here.
In the '30s, what did
Muller and McClintock do
that set the stage for
what you were doing?
- The function of telomeres,
in terms of this protective cap
that's what H.J. Muller
and Barbara McClintock
showed, was that,
Mueller was working in Drosophila
and McClintock in corn or maize,
showed that there must be
something protective at the end
because when you break
that chromosome end,
that you get the chromosome
is either degraded
or it will fuse with other chromosomes.
So they were the first to
functionally define the telomere
as we just described it.
Then it was in the 1970s
that Elizabeth Blackburn,
working together with Joe Gall,
showed the molecular
characteristics of the telomere.
So they defined the actual
DNA sequence at the time.
Then understanding that
molecular characteristic,
we could then go forward
and ask questions about
how the end of the
chromosome is maintained.
- Explain a little more what understanding
the end and the molecular
structure at the end,
what is that about?
In other words, it's,
Help me understand that.
- If you understand the detailed
make-up of the chromosome,
then that allows one to do experiments
to be able to test how is it
that the end of the
chromosome can be maintained.
But if you don't know what
it functionally is made of,
then you can't design
experiments around that.
So, it was really understanding
that DNA sequence,
and, in the case of the telomere sequence
that Liz Blackburn defined,
it was from the ciliated
protozoan Tetrahymena,
which has 40,000 chromosomes.
- So you pick a one-cell organism
that's doing a lot of this work.
- Exactly.
It's got 40,000 chromosomes,
so you go to the source
to find out what the
material is actually made of.
They found that it was this
very simple, repeated sequence.
In DNA we use the four-letter alphabet
for the building blocks of the DNA.
And that's T, C, A and G.
But what they found was that this telomere
was made up of a very, very
repetitive TTGGGG TTGGGG TTGGGG.
Hundreds of repeats.
Very, very simple and repetitive,
and that that's what actually
provides the protective cap
at the end of the chromosome.
- Does that mean that the cap
is made up of individual caps
or it's one continuous structure?
- It's one continuous structure and then
that DNA sequence actually has
proteins that bind along it
to carry out the function of the telomere.
- Do different organisms
have different lengths
and then, throughout the aging process,
what happens to these caps?
- At first it was only identified
in these single-cell ciliates and then,
as more people started doing experiments,
one you know what an initial sequence is,
then it gives you something in mind
to look in other organisms.
So, one of the very nice things
about working on something as
fundamental as the telomere
is that things that are that
fundamental inside cells
tend to be conserved
throughout organisms and so,
how it's solved in one organism
will tend to be true in
many, many organisms.
It turned out that that was
very true for telomeres.
So as people started identifying
telomere sequences in different organisms,
there were also these simple, repeated
sequences on the ends of chromosomes.
So, we were able to
then do more experiments
to try and understand
how those are maintained.
- Blackburn and her associate, Gall,
part of their experimentation
which really pushed this along
was the discovery
that you could take one organism
and, essentially, build caps
in another related organism,
but a different organism.
- So that was the experiment
that had been done
just before I came to
Berkeley and that was
a collaboration of Liz
Blackburn with Jack Szostak
and they took a piece of DNA from yeast,
which is normally a circle,
and then they opened that circle
and added the telomeres
that they had identified,
that Liz had identified from Tetrahymena.
So, instead of a circle, they now had
what would be a linear
chromosome, like most chromosomes.
Quite remarkably, they found that
when they took that linear
piece of DNA with telomeres
and put it inside yeast cells,
and Tetrahymena and yeast are
in two different kingdoms of life,
that that function,
that telomere function,
was maintained inside the yeast.
So the telomeres functioned
and you now had this linear chromosome.
That was really a key experiment,
but even more importantly,
was then going and looking to see,
within those yeast cells,
that Tetrahymena telomere
had a little bit of telomere
sequences added onto it
that were yeast-specific
sequences as it was dividing.
And that provided the clue
that made Liz and Jack
suggest this mechanism,
how is it that telomeres
are actually maintained?
They made the very bold
proposal that, maybe,
there is an enzyme that actually will just
add these repeated sequences
onto the ends of chromosomes.
So, as I said, normally you
would expect the telomeres
to shorten progressively
with each cell division,
but they proposed that, if
you can then add something,
then you can balance out the
shortening with addition.
So that's what I then set out to test
when I came to work with Liz Blackburn.
- Just out of curiosity, is the sequence
in the different organisms the same?
- It's not exactly the same.
It's the same flavor.
That is, it's tandemly repeated sequences.
But, very conveniently, the yeast sequence
is just slightly different
than the Tetrahymena sequence.
So you could see that you
had Tetrahymena telomeres
and then there was a
transition into yeast telomeres
at the very end of the sequence,
which allowed them then to propose
that they could be added by an enzyme.
- So, okay, you're a
first-year graduate student.
You've studied enough to
know who you wanna study with
and you have been exposed to the history
that we've just talked
about in terms of discovery.
So then what did you say to yourself
about what you wanted to focus on?
- For first-year graduate
students, at least at the time,
and I think this is still true,
is you're required to do projects
in three different laboratories.
So I did a project in one laboratory
and then I did a project
with Liz Blackburn
on telomeres from unrelated
an unrelated organism,
and then I did a third project.
You're not officially allowed
to make a deal with who
you're gonna work with
until some time in May of the first year.
I knew that I wanted to work with Liz
during the time that I had
done the rotation with her
and I knew about this idea,
how do chromosomes replicate,
how are they maintained,
and I thought that that was
the most exciting thing
going on in telomeres.
So, in May, at the end
of my third rotation,
I made an appointment to go and see Liz
and I had two things
that I wanted to ask her.
One is, can I work with you?
And two is, can I work on this project?
I was thrilled because
she said yes to both
and the conversation
lasted maybe five minutes.
And then, once I finished
up my third project,
I went back to Liz's
lab and started the work
to try and identify, is there such a thing
which will add these telomeric sequences
onto the ends of chromosomes?
- It sounds to me like,
just following your
intellectual journey here,
that you were really,
everything in your life
came together to prepare
you for this choice
of what you wanted to work
with and set about doing it.
- It just seemed like
the obvious thing to do
because it was a very exciting problem
that I was just curious about.
But, certainly, that is built up by
my experiences from the past
that brought me to that point
where I felt that this was
an interesting project.
And Liz was very interested in this
and she was happy to have
somebody that wanted to pursue it.
- You start this work and then,
what is involved in the experimentation
that says, okay, what's going on here
and how do I play with these
creatures, shall we say,
or these chromosomes, to
figure out what's going on?
At some point I read you
said, you need a strategy to,
and so, what was the strategy you set upon
and what were the different
things you had to adjust
to come up--
- So it's an empirical science
and we started, of course,
again with Tetrahymena.
Tetrahymena has 40,000 chromosomes.
Then it must have a lot of whatever it is
that is needed to
maintain the chromosomes.
So we used Tetrahymena
cells and, basically,
made a little cocktail of
ground-up Tetrahymena cells
with what we hope would be
the right pH and buffers
and concentration.
But then the key was,
really, trying to understand
how we were gonna look for
something being elongated.
We tried a variety of different things.
We tried isolating a specific piece of DNA
that had a little bit of
telomeric sequence on it.
Did experiments for five
or six months with that,
getting little hints here and there.
But it was really, because
it's an empirical science,
it was just trying different things.
It was about nine months after
starting these experiments
where every day I'd come in
and make a little cocktail
of the Tetrahymena cells and put them in
with some radioactive DNA precursors
to look if those precursors
would be elongating something.
And then, instead of doing a DNA fragment,
I switched to trying, well,
maybe a synthetic DNA oligonucleotide
would be the thing that
could be elongated.
The very first time that
I did that experiment,
when I came in to develop
the result of the experiment,
I saw this pattern that looked like
a six-base repeating pattern of DNA.
The key, in retrospect, was in switching
to using that DNA oligonucleotide,
not because it was synthetic,
but because of the amount
that you could get in
because it was so short.
It was 18 nucleotides long,
18 building blocks of the DNA,
as opposed to something
that was a thousand or more.
Because of that, there could be
more molecules in the experiment
because it's so small that,
when you're adding a certain amount,
the number of ends that were there
was over a thousand-fold of
what we had been adding before.
So it was just trying different things.
It was very clear, as soon as we had
enough of the material in the extract,
that there was this repeating pattern.
But that's when things got interesting
because it was like,
wow, this is exciting.
There's something that
we expect to see here.
But then it's like, what
could be fooling us?
And there was a whole 'nother year then,
of trying to figure out,
maybe this was a known enzyme
and we were just interpreting
it in a certain way.
We had to then convince ourselves
that this really was something new.
And this is something that I
talk to students about often,
is that, when you have something
that's new and exciting,
rather than saying, oh,
I wanna find evidence
to support my hypothesis, instead,
we tried to bash down our own hypothesis
and to find ways to knock it down,
to find out, how could
this possibly be wrong?
Because I would rather
disprove my own crazy idea
than have somebody else disprove it.
And so--
- We'll talk about what you
had to do in the following,
but I just wanna go
back to this aha moment.
I believe I read that
this was on Christmas day
that you came in, you
see what has happened,
and so this was your wow moment.
Then what did you do?
You went home and, you were so excited
and you did what we all do,
played Bruce Springsteen.
- Exactly.
Because the pattern was
something that was suggestive
that this could really be
something very exciting.
And then after that, it was, well,
what else could be fooling us here?
- I wanna go back to this thing about
the collegiality because the new item
that you were using
that made the difference
was actually something that
you were able to borrow
from a colleague who had
been working on this the,
- Yes, there was somebody else
in the lab, Eric Henderson,
at the time, that was working on actually
the structure of these
DNA oligonucleotides
and doing nuclear magnetic
resonance to try and understand.
So he was just doing
experiments just with this.
So he had it in the laboratory and I said,
well, can I have some of that
to try in this elongation experiment?
- So once you see this
lengthening process, then the,
you're then asking yourself,
well what is this enzyme
and where is it coming from?
Is that the--
- Is it really a new enzyme
that is just adding onto
the ends of chromosomes?
Nobody had ever heard of
anything like that before.
Typically, if you have
something that makes DNA,
what it does is, it has something to copy,
what we call a template.
So a typical DNA synthesis
is, there's a template there
and then the DNA polymerase as we call it,
the thing that makes the DNA,
just copies what is there.
So we were wondering,
maybe there's some
small template somewhere
that we don't know about and, really,
this is just a normal DNA polymerase
that is making these copies.
And so, we then set out to devise
a series of experiments to disprove
or to rule out that it
was just a DNA polymerase.
That took about a year's time.
So, the discovery was
made in December of '84
and the paper was published
in December of '85.
- What, then, is involved
in the experiments
that followed in the next year?
Seeing where this enzyme was coming from
or what made its work possible?
- If we could rule out that there was
some other template that was being copied.
So, purifying the enzyme,
trying to get rid of
any contaminating DNA that might be there.
But what really ended up convincing us
was really the converse of the experiment
that Liz Blackburn and
Jack Szostak had done,
because what they had done was
to take Tetrahymena telomeres
and put them into a yeast cell
and see that yeast
sequences were added on.
So what we decided to try, was
to make a synthetic telomere
of the yeast sequence
and put that into a Tetrahymena extract.
Sure enough, it was elongated
and the yeast sequence
was the initial sequence,
but what was added was
the Tetrahymena repeat.
- Which was the opposite
of what had happened--
- Which is the opposite,
is exactly the converse of
the previous experiment.
Because of the way that
the sequences are set up,
there was a slight shift
in the banding pattern
that we saw on the gel
and that was the second aha moment
of this series of experiments
that went into the first paper
because, then, I was really convinced
that it wasn't just copying
something that was already there
and that it probably was actually
adding onto the end of the chromosome.
- Now when you say a shift in the banding,
you mean the, explain that.
- The way, as I mentioned,
they have this six-base
periodicity that was the six nucleotides
that are added, TTAGGG,
well, the yeast sequence, it turned out,
didn't have four Gs in
the initial template,
the initial primer that
we were putting in.
It only has three because
that's the yeast sequence.
So, the pattern then, has to make four Gs
and so it adds one before then
going into the rest of the pattern,
so everything is shifted up by
one with that yeast sequence,
which, really, fascinated us.
- The next step, as I understand it,
and, again, this is not my background,
so I'm trying to get you here to explicate
and you're really doing a great job here.
When does RNA, the realization
that RNA has something to do with this,
Explain that--
- So that was the next.
Once we convinced ourselves
that we really have
a new enzyme that is
actually taking an end
and adding things on to it,
then the question becomes,
well where does that information come,
how does it know how
to make TTGGGG TTGGGG?
Because typically things
do copy a template.
And that's when we thought, well, perhaps,
the enzyme itself has,
within it, a little template
and that, perhaps, could be made of RNA.
So that was the next thing
we then set out to test is,
could it be that this enzyme
is what we call an RNP enzyme?
It has both protein and RNA within it.
And that was the next
series of experiments
that we identified
something that looked like
it might be an RNA template.
But then we had to ask ourselves,
can we really prove that
it is the RNA template?
Another series of
experiments to come at it
from a variety of different angles
to ask, could we be being fooled
just because you take the enzyme
and treat with something
that destroys RNase
and activity goes away?
Is that because there's an RNA template
or is that for some other reason?
So it was really setting
ourselves a series of challenges.
- When you published your initial findings
and then the ones that followed,
how controversial was what you were saying
for the field at that time?
You said you had to be
your own devil's advocate.
So, clearly, you anticipated
that people would be coming at you
and what did you anticipate and--
- I just to be sure that we were right
if we were gonna go out on a limb
and propose something like this.
There was an alternative model
whereby one could use a DNA recombination
to get this elongation.
So there were two models
that were out there
that were published and we were
looking for evidence for one of them.
But, it's very interesting
because it didn't end up
really being too controversial.
People accepted it.
We had to make some changes to the paper,
but, all along, people
said, well, isn't that cute?
That's a nice little thing that they do
off in this organism, Tetrahymena.
There wasn't any
realization that this might
have some sort of a general role.
Now, what we know about
telomeres and telomerase
and they play a major
role in human disease,
and we had no concept of that back then.
We were just trying to
understand the fundamentals
of how telomeres were maintained.
We didn't even know that
the human telomeric sequence
was this same repeated, kind of
very simple telomeric repeats.
So I wouldn't say that it was,
necessarily, controversial, but,
We published in good journals,
but it wasn't taken as a huge deal.
- So your aha moment, in a way,
wasn't a big aha for the community
generally because it wasn't clear,
Well, so what.
- For the telomere community,
the group of, maybe,
40 labs across the world
that worked on telomeres,
it was a big deal.
But I would say, the
molecular biology in general,
telomeres weren't really on the radar.
There's some little problem
over here with replication
but what's that got to do
with people who are interested
in understanding how genes are transcribed
and regulation and
development of organisms?
So the fields that were
really big-deal fields
were a little bit aside
from what we were doing.
So it was sort of on the side.
- So, in a way, we're learning here,
something about leadership and science
because here we have curious
people building on a tradition,
learning stuff from their colleagues
that helps inform what they're doing
and, in a way, opening
up a whole new field.
So, initially, you're opening up the field
for the people who study these telomeres,
but now we go on to say, hey,
this may have something to do
with our understanding of
cancer, cystic fibrosis
and other things.
Talk a little about that next step.
- So there had been
experiments, or proposals,
back in the 1970s.
So this idea about how
when you replicate the
end of a chromosome,
you can't replicate to the very end.
Liz Blackburn and I were
aware of a publication
that Jim Watson, the
discoverer of DNA, had proposed
showing that you can't replicate
to the very end of the chromosome.
So we were citing his papers all along.
Well, it turns out that,
around the same time,
there was a Russian
scientist, Alexey Olovnikov,
who had, independently,
come up with the same idea,
but he didn't call the ends
of the chromosomes telomeres,
he called them margins and so,
his paper was called a
theory of marginotomy,
so it wasn't pulled up
by any of our references.
But a colleague of mine,
who I met while I was in
graduate school, Cal Harley,
who worked in the field
of cellular senescence,
was aware of this paper and
that this fellow, Olovnikov,
had proposed, not only
did the telomeres shorten,
but that might play a
role in the fact that,
when you take primary human
cells and put them into culture,
they go through a certain
number of divisions
and then they stop dividing.
And that's known as the Hayflick limit,
proposed by Len Hayflick in the 1960s,
that there's a finite lifespan
that normal human cells have.
So, in talking with Cal Harley,
he made me aware of this other literature
which was going back to the '70s as well.
So then, when the human telomeric sequence
was identified, which wasn't until 19,
I think it was 1988, was the presentation
at a conference that I was
at at Cold Spring Harbor,
and I believe the publication was in 1989.
Then, once we knew what the
sequence was, so, really,
understanding what the
components are is enabling,
once we understood that, then
we could do an experiment
to ask, what does happen
to human chromosomes?
So I collaborated with Cal Harley,
and this is what's nice about science
is that you can do experiments
in a blinded fashion.
Because I really like to
know what is the truth,
and if you do a blinded experiment,
and you don't have any way of pre-judging
what the answer is, then you
can really believe it's true.
So Cal Harley had grown some
of these human cells in culture
for a number of divisions,
and then he prepared the
DNA and he sent it to me
with just numbers on the tubes.
I then took that DNA and was able to
look at the length of the telomeres
because I now knew the
sequence of the human telomere.
So I did this experiment
and some were long
and some were short and some
were long and some were short
and then I called him up and
said, okay, what's the key?
And sure enough, those cells
that had been dividing for more times
had shorter telomeres than the ones that,
And, again, that was very satisfying
because I couldn't have
been biased in any way
because I didn't know,
when I did the experiment,
what the results would be.
- So help us understand what the meaning,
the possible meanings of this is for
coming up with, say, drugs
for cancer, and so on.
- What we were able to show is that,
this cellular senescence,
that is when you take cells
and they divide for a
limited time in culture,
that the telomeres would limit them
from dividing more times.
One thought, at the time,
and now I think it's also,
there's support for it,
is that the fact that
normal cells only go through
a finite number of divisions,
means that cancer cells have to
have something wrong with them
and perhaps the telomeres
might play a role in that.
So the finding of the
telomeres that shorten
with normal cells in culture,
then led to the question of, well,
what happens with cancer cells?
Because the difference in a cancer cell
is that it goes through many
more rounds of divisions
than it normally should.
So, sure enough, again, with Cal Harley
and Silvia Bacchetti, we
were able to show that,
when the normal cell
becomes a cancer cell,
now this enzyme telomerase becomes active.
So, telomerase is active in cancer cells
and not as active in the normal cells.
- So that if you could figure out
a way to work on that process,
then you might have a pathway
to all kinds of discoveries.
- There were many thoughts
and many papers published,
that if you had a way
to inhibit telomerase,
you could inhibit the
growth of cancer cells.
Now that we know a little bit more
about the role of
telomerase in normal cells
because, as it turns out,
it's not just cancer cells
which have to divide many times,
there are cells in your body,
which have to replenish other cells.
One example, for instance,
is the blood cells.
Within the bone marrow,
there are cells that normally
divide every day to allow
new blood cells to be born
because blood cells have
a very limited lifespan.
So there are normal
cells in the human body
which also have to have telomerase
to be able to maintain their telomeres.
So, the initial story,
which was a cancer story,
we are very interested in that still
and we've done a lot of
experiments to show that,
in fact, limiting the telomere lengthening
does limit the growth of the cancer cell.
But if you're gonna take that as a way
to do some sort of therapeutics,
you also now have to keep in mind,
the role of telomerase in normal cells.
- I see.
So, how
it was when you saw these other pathways
and the general implication
for medicine and disease and so on,
that you were then recognized
with the Nobel Prize,
'cause it took, there was no Nobel Prize
when you made the initial discovery.
- Right, the initial discovery was just
understanding the elongation
of telomeres in Tetrahymena.
But then, by continuing
to follow our curiosity,
I collaborated with Cal Harley
on the senescence side of things,
and then got interested in understanding
the role of telomerase in cancer.
We made a mouse that
doesn't have any telomerase
and looked at what happens
and what are the consequences
of not having telomerase
and how does that affect cancer?
By just continuing to be
able to follow our curiosity,
which is what's so nice about
being able to work in academia
and the National Institutes of Health
has supported my research
for the last 30 years
and, if I can write a grant
that's interesting enough,
then I could follow and do those things.
So, by following those things up,
the consequences then for
human health became clear.
The thing, as you're saying
about the Nobel Prize,
is that it's given for
physiology or medicine and so,
the medical implications of the telomerase
and the role in cancer and in
stem cells became apparent.
Then, what the Swedish Academy looks at
is then, okay, who was it
that made the discovery
that allowed this to be clear?
- In an interview you gave
when you won the Nobel Prize,
you made a point that I
found very interesting,
which is that, it was
very important for you
to bring your children to
your first press conference.
Talk a little about that
because you make the point
that men don't do that when
they win the Nobel Prize,
or hadn't done it.
- Oh, I forgot that I had made that point.
But certainly I wanted
my children to be there.
I wanted them to share the day with me.
Mostly that's how I felt, that
it was a family event and so,
when I got the call at
five o'clock in the morning
and then after the phone call
with the Swedish Academy,
I went and I woke up
my children and I said,
by the way, I won the Nobel Prize
and the first thing my son said was,
"Do I have to go to
school today?" (laughs)
(Harry laughs)
Then I said, nope, you don't
have to go to school today.
- The reason I wanted to pursue this is
it's really about, it's saying something
about women and science,
as opposed to men,
and I wanted to talk a little about that.
So, in this work, obviously,
two women are very important in the work
and we're grappling with
the issue as a nation
of how do we get more women into science.
Talk a little about what women bring
and how to scientific discovery.
You're still doing the same process.
It's not as if you're
inventing a new science,
but talk a little about
why we need more women
and what they bring to the table.
- Well, the fact that there's only about
30% at the assistant professor level,
30% and even higher at the,
at higher ranks of women in science,
really is just unfortunate in terms of
the amount of brain power that
we have in the United States.
If we're gonna have 50% of the people
that may have creative ideas
not really be able to engage,
then that certainly takes away a lot of
the possibilities for discoveries.
So I certainly don't think
that women, necessarily,
have anything unique to offer
for the scientific enterprise
but they have a lot to offer,
and a lot of times the way our
institutions are structured,
women aren't included in that process.
And so, science is to the
detriment because of that.
- What can we do about the structures?
What, in particular, holds women back?
- I think that that's a
really, a larger issue
than just women in science.
That really has more to do
with our society in general
because, in society at large,
there are discussions ongoing
about women at higher
positions in business,
on corporate boards, on
various institutions like that.
So I don't think that science
is unique in this area,
that, as a society, we have certain norms
about how men are perceived
and what kinds of jobs they should have
and how women are perceived.
Although a great amount
of change has occurred,
for instance, since my
mother's generation,
really, the numbers haven't followed suit.
For instance, when I was at
Berkeley in graduate school
50% of us were women in graduate school.
But that has not tracked along.
You would expect, then, if
it were, as people have said,
it's a pipeline issue.
There aren't enough women
coming into the sciences.
If it were a pipeline
issue, we would be at 50%
at the level of full professors now,
and we're at the 10 or so percent level.
So, it's not a pipeline issue.
I'm certainly not an expert
in what are the causes
but I've read a number of reports.
There was a very nice report
by the Association of University Women
that suggested that it's a leaky pipeline
that, although there
are 50% women coming in,
that, at the different transitions, from
being a graduate student to
being a post-doctoral fellow,
being a post-doctoral fellow
to an assistant professor,
at each stage, more and more women decide
not to go on in the pipeline.
So they're coming out of the
pipeline and the questions is,
why and what are the structures
that we have in place in science,
but also in general in society, that
more women make those choices
than men make those choices?
- You're suggesting that it may
be a larger structural issue
that applies to the society in general.
- I, certainly, know when
I listen to national fora
on these kinds of topics,
the issues that I hear
for women in banking and women in business
are very similar and,
actually, I feel like
the women in science probably
have a little bit of an advantage
because if I were a banker today
I would have to be certain hours at work
and I do have two children,
and so it's nice for me
to not have to be quite so constricted,
proscripted in how many hours I'm at work.
If I have to go off and
see my son in a play
or something like that, I can do that.
I have a lot more flexibility
as an academic scientist
than I would in other areas.
So, but yet, still the
same kinds of issues
of this leaky pipeline
exist across the country.
I was very interested
when Anne-Marie Slaughter
who was at Princeton and was working
with Hillary Clinton
in the State Department
came out with a very provocative
paper in The Atlantic
on why women still can't have it all.
And clearly, even in her
field, in political science,
there's very, very similar issues
that prevent women from advancing.
- If we look back at your
intellectual journey,
you were blessed with
many informal mechanisms,
formal, informal
environments that made you
the great scientist that you became.
I wanna ask you about science education.
You were blessed with a family environment
in which you breathed
science even if you didn't
decide you wanted to be a physicist.
At Santa Barbara, it was a very,
it was a setting which was not formal
and that would draw on your strengths
and really prepare you for science.
When you came here, you were lucky enough
to work with a distinguished
woman scientist,
and that might have
been sort of conducive.
So, do you have any thoughts on what
your journey tells us
about what we might do
with regard to science
education generally?
- The one thing that was very
clear that helped me a lot
was being able to try
out different things,
because sometimes you can't
just read about something
and say, yes, that's what I want to do.
To find out what fits intellectually,
sometimes you actually have
to be in the situation.
So that's something I definitely encourage
all young scientists or
young people in any area,
is to go out and experience
a lot of different things.
Because when you're in the environment,
you can then see what captures
and what fits best with
your intellectual style.
And then you can know what it
is that you want to pursue.
So I think that having
those kinds of opportunities
in a number of different settings
was really very, very helpful to me.
- And sorta looking to the
future of the work that you do,
what vistas do you see in terms of
questions that we have to answer
along the path that
you have helped define?
- Well this issue of telomeres
and cellular senescence
has really become much more
focused on age-related disease
and the role of telomeres
in age-related disease.
I mentioned the blood cells.
So, bone marrow requiring telomerase.
It turns out that there are a
number of age-related diseases
like immune senescence,
bone marrow failure,
something called pulmonary
fibrosis, liver fibrosis.
There are these diseases that
tend to be diseases of aging,
where the short telomeres
clearly play a causal
role in those diseases.
So, we're even more interested now
in understanding the detailed mechanisms
of how telomeres are maintained.
And despite everything that we've done
for the past 25 years,
there's still a lot
that we don't understand
about the regulation of this process
of the telomere elongation
and how does it know how much to elongate
and, if it doesn't elongate enough,
then people are at risk for
these age-related diseases.
So, really understanding that,
and we have to know more
of the actual components
because that's an enabling
kind of discovery.
So there are still many
open-ended questions
about both the detailed mechanism
and then how that relates to disease.
Why are there these particular
age-related diseases
that are sensitive to
telomeres and not others?
So, I really think that there's
a huge amount still to
be done in this area.
- Well, on that note, Professor Greider,
I wanna thank you very much
for coming back to Berkeley
to deliver the Hitchcock lecture
and taking the time to be on our program.
Thank you very--
- It was my pleasure.
Thank you.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat electronic music)